I gotta pull up this story from the New
York Times because boy you want to talk
about world war three the New York Times
reports the U.S believes ukrainians were
behind an assassination in Russia just
say in the headline the assassination of
Daria dugina American officials said
they were not aware of the plan ahead of
time for the attack that killed Daria
dugina and that they had admonished
Ukraine over it oh admonished
so what do you think Russia is going to
say to that that's it's War right
they're not even Russia's not even
calling this a war yet what do you think
the people I mean this is the kind of
thing with with U.S admission now that
will boost morale among Russians so did
you see the uh clip of Jeffrey sacks on
Bloomberg recently that's gone kind of
viral where he is basically saying hey
the rest of the world the Optics on this
is the U.S blew up this Nordstrom
Pipeline and actually this conflict is a
proxy war between the United States and
Russia he's like that's how everybody
else and they were like whoa well hold
on there we'll hold I don't know about
that exactly well I've actually so the
two minute clip that's going around on
Twitter there's an eight minute clip and
Jeffrey sacks Nails it throughout I
actually covered it yesterday but that's
the thing the rest of the world already
understands the narrative is the United
States is in a full-on proxy war with
Russia we're not even acknowledging that
I mean it's not it's not a proxy war
it's War NATO is is in Poland the Supply
Military supplies are being delivered to
Ukraine and it's so obvious that NATO is
not now worried Russia will strike
Poland because that's where they're
delivering the weapons so it's like the
way I describe it let's say there's a
dude throwing rocks at you and you're
like bro stop throwing rocks at me and
behind him is another guy handing him
rocks are we gonna be like the guy
handing him rocks has nothing to do with
this and we're not fighting no both of
them are at war with you so it's not a
proxy war we've got American citizens
and NATO citizens on the ground in
Ukraine and they're going we're just
volunteers oh spare me dude NATO is
delivering weapons tanks they just said
a bunch of Apache helicopters to Poland
Poland now wants nukes and then those
weapons are being delivered to American
veterans who are fighting as mercenaries
for Ukraine that's a technicality I
don't think Vladimir Putin is looking at
that and going well he's not formally
working for the U.S no he's just armored
by them a citizen of the country and
benefits from it and fighting for a
country that is being massively funded
the tune of billions of dollars by the
U.S come on Putin's not some [ __ ] who's
like looking over a legal document being
like well I would declare war on NATO
but they found all the loopholes they're
able to go to war with us but it's not
formal so what am I supposed to similar
to Vietnam where the Chinese were
sending the North Vietnamese all sorts
of weapons and tanks and but we didn't
strike China because or Russia I think
the Russians were involved with
spreading it to North North Korea or
North Vietnam too
um because it's but it's really the
military contractors are profiting off
of limited War they don't want a total
war they don't want Russia to attack
Poland they don't want the U.S to drop
bombs in Moscow they want to just keep
selling weapons to the front to these
poor ukrainians who are in this flat
terrain that are just getting artillery
shelled and and then they keep profiting
it's a really War for profit I think and
a small amount of land that Putin wants
to connect to Crimea
well the Tim's point on the proxy
um Michael Tracy who I follow on Twitter
I think he does some really good work is
outright saying that U.S soldiers are in
command and control of the ground
Warfare there of course come on but I
would take it a step further and say
well our starlink systems are arming The
Ghost and Sidewinder drones that are
killing Russian soldiers the
concentration of starlink there is
twelve thousand it's the greatest
concentration on the planet I would say
that's overt Warfare and the U.S
provided the intelligence used by The
ukrainians Who used NATO weapons to blow
up the flagship of of Putin's or
Russia's uh Black Sea uh Fleet so uh
like come on yeah World War II the U.S
was selling weapons to England for a
layer is giving them lendlies they
weren't even charging them and the
Germans knew but the Germans like well
this sucks we can't declare war on
America because that will lose the war
but then eventually when after the
United States made that argument
actually that he lost 80 million dollars
on their latest satellite launches into
the Ukraine you know he put out that
poll on you know that solution but if
you follow that thread he says look we
actually lost money sending these
starlink satellites out there so he's
admitting that they're being used in
Warfare but he wants to kind of paint
the picture it's just for communications
for the good guys but again they're
hooking up to drones that are taking
real lives you know that's real Warfare
in my opinion and uh you know Eric
Schmidt the former CEO of Google came
out and called Elon Musk the true hero
of the Ukrainian war and now Elon Musk
is being labeled a traitor to the
Ukrainian people which is absolutely
totally absurd and it's not just
satellite uh Internet it's also
satellite images it's also GPS tracking
it's also troop movements that the
United States is advising the Ukrainian
troops saying hey we're going to say
we're going to kerasan but really we're
going to Lyman and then now we're going
to fake Lyman now we're going to kirison
because this is how the troops are
moving in this specific region this is
the weak spots that we see here and with
the the the the Weaponry that they have
the advanced technology today I saw a
video of a Ukrainian using a drone own
denial weapon against a Russian DGI
mavic drone that was flying over getting
reconnaissance and a Russian soldier had
this huge uh you know gun that was
provided to him by the West literally
Soldier Ukrainian Ukrainian children had
this huge gun that that pointed at the
Drone and just took it down right away
did they reuse it did they recover it
and then use it probably yeah you know
because the Russians a lot of them are
buying you know dgis off of the private
market and literally using them for
reconnaissance meanwhile the United
States is using satellite imagery to you
know get all the information about where
where they are the exact GPS coordinates
the coordinates are put into the
starlink satellites connected to the
weaponries the weapons and the missiles
just fly directly on top of the Russians
you know that there are psychotic nerds
that are just like tracking the data
analytics I'm like oh this is how people
act when they're think they're at War
and Afraid how what if we turn up the
fear oh this is how they act oh they
send weapons oh they they tend to go
further south where it's warmer when
they're afraid oh you know like weird
crazy the psychopathic scientists that
are like pushing it but today also very
interestingly it's it's it's very
captivating to see technology play such
an active role in this uh a proxy war
between the East and the West because
also very interestingly the Ukrainian
government also expelled Iranian
diplomats from their country
specifically because Iran provided
suicide drones to the Russians that they
have allegedly used today on a military
uh Camp inside of Kiev so there's big
news today that Iranian drone struck
inside of Kiev uh and that was
specifically why ukrainians expelled
Iranian uh diplomats
suicide drone was it like strapped to
the bomb or something no it's just it's
just a drone that flies up and then when
it lands it explodes so this is
something you mentioned earlier Business
Insider Russia's space agency Chief
claimed his Nation could destroy NATO
countries in half an hour during a
nuclear war so uh highlighting this when
you have the us being like Oh Ukraine
just assassinated the daughter a
prominent reporter and the daughter of a
prominent uh influencer or whatever you
want to call him philosopher in Russia
and we're we're just going along with
what they're doing they are going to
drag us into a war where they're they
they are capable of and directly
threatening to wipe out the entirety of
the of NATO which includes us I would
much prefer not to be nuked because I've
grown quite fond of living so uh for
everybody else maybe we can tell Ukraine
to knock off this kind of insanity if
you want to defend your land because
Russia's invading totally get it going
into Russia and killing some dude's
daughter and a prominent journalist hey
maybe that's a big big mistake
well there are War when you're at War
there's no nothing's off the top that's
true this idea that you know I'm writing
these articles and they're like Putin's
illegal Invasion I'm like oh I'm sure
Putin cares about what you think is
legal yeah it's it's it really is insane
that we have these concepts of like war
crimes now I get it to a certain degree
we're like we're gonna try and stop
these things from happening and create
some kind of framework for if you do it
there will be severe penalties when we
defeat you but it's like at the same
time yo if somebody is fighting against
you to with the intent to kill you
they're gonna do anything and everything
your laws are meaningless there's that
gentleman War where if you're fighting
the enemy you know you want to capture
their commander and then sell them back
rather than kill them you don't want to
kill everybody you want you want a
profit off the war that's the point of
the war is you want to come up better
afterwards so right but if we're talking
about existential conflict when we're
talking about like you know with the
colonial wars it was like over territory
and new lands and things like that then
they're gonna be like okay fine you can
take that territory oh we've lost Quebec
you know or whatever
but what we're talking about here is
Putin thinking or saying that well he
says he would use nuclear weapons if
there's an existential threat to Russia
NATO encroaching on its borders and
cutting off its ability to sell fuel
into Europe is probably an existential
threat to Russia this is not Russia's
interests overseas this is their actual
border being threatened so I don't think
they're going to play any games where
they're alike we'll capture them and
sell them back no they're going to be
like destroy them
maybe but I don't think that they want
the Russia to get nuked like if Russia
if nukes drop all over Russia Russian
cities they lose so
I think of nuke struck it's mutually
Disturbed destruction I can't believe
people aren't talking more about that
you don't think so huh you think that we
can have kind of these tactical Nuclear
Wars where only certain areas are hit
and it doesn't just set off that Chain
Reaction yep so tactical news first
we'll start with tactical news being
much lower yield we're not talking about
an ICBM wiping out a million people
we're talking about 10 000 to 100 000
depending on the yield of the Tactical
nuke really really bad but there was a
great quote I can't remember who who
just said it recently they said if Putin
nukes a issues a nuclear strike on a
NATO Nation there will not be a nuclear
response because the American president
would have to be insane to sacrifice
Boston for posnan so if Putin were to
Nuke that the us is going to be like if
we respond they'll respond again and
then we will actually get hit ourselves
in our homeland and be forced to defend
ourselves here if the fighting stays
over there they'll probably respond with
full-scale conventional Warfare not a
nuclear strike there's no reason for
Putin right now to just be like I'm
gonna Nuke DC now if you if you fired a
nuke at DC yeah maybe we would fire a
nuke back at Moscow or something and
that's the deterrent don't do it because
we'll do it back we'd find like 100
nukes back at my like 30 at Moscow 30 at
Novus beers you know all over the spot
in the United States if Putin is using
nuclear artillery and tactical nukes in
Ukraine ain't nobody gonna respond if
they drop 100 kiloton bomb on Kiev and
kill 20 30 000 people NATO will not nuke
back that that's because Ukraine is not
a NATO nation and no NATO nation is
going to sacrifice their capital for
anything in Ukraine
right now they're content with sending
supplies and having them fight they
don't want Russia to win but I don't see
you know Poland's asking for nukes I
don't see Poland sacrificing poznan for
Kiev Kiev to get hit and they're going
to be like we don't want to get hit next
so we got to keep we're not going to
respond in kind not only that but they
can't even respond if they wanted to
they have no nukes I guess my greatest
fear is if any kind of nuclear strike
happens anywhere our world changes
overnight and it just gives you this
excuse to roll out all sorts of Martial
law slash authoritarian measures
wherever you know it wouldn't matter
which side it was on like if like say
that happened say 10 000 people get
taken out and attack attack tactical
strike in the Ukraine you don't think
that this Administration here would
utilize that not only to instill fear on
the American public but pass certain
executive orders and measures that would
restrict yeah I mean that's directive 51
you guys know directive 51. man about it
you ever play the game the division no I
never played oh come on that game's
great was there a bush uh directive Bush
director nine afterward and we it was I
think it was in like 2007 we're not sure
if it's legal it's never been tested but
presidential National Security
Presidential Directive 51 allows the
president to basically overwrite the U.S
government and create a new one yeah
that was George Bush George Bush and I
believe Obama revised it since since
then it's gone through several changes
many people have said it's a nonsense
executive order because the executive
branch doesn't have the authority to
overthrow the US government because of
an emergency but the language of it is
nuts it basically says if any kind of
disaster happens anywhere the president
of the United States can declare an
enduring constitutional government and
install a continuity coordinator who now
runs all of the branches and it creates
one branch that controls everything this
would be quote any incident regardless
of location that results in
extraordinary levels of mass casualties
damage or disruption severely affecting
the U.S population infrastructure
environment economy or government
functions disruption severely affecting
the U.S population so like what a
hurricane a storm a blackout yes yeah
exactly so it's not been tested many
people think that if they tried to do it
there'd be challenges the problem is in
a circumstance where they do declare I
think it's been updated and there's a
different executive order on the books
now but in the event that something
happens like a nuke does drop on Kiev
I really doubt there's going to be it's
gonna no one in the United States is
gonna be able to do anything about it if
they do it because it would just be
civil war
you're going to get people who are going
to be like dude a nuke was dropped I
ain't going I'm I'm not I'm not I'm not
standing up I'm not
do whatever right most people will
probably say I'm scared of nukes so when
the government says we're at War and
this is the way it is they'll just say
okay I'm concerned of false Flags here
because anybody could drop a nuke
anywhere well that's my point if a nuke
goes up no one knows who actually did it
you know who they'll blame right
regardless Russia is going to get blamed
I've been blaming Russia for everything
it's like some dudes like walking and
Democrat stubs his tone he's like ah
Putin put that rock there and you know
Donald Trump wins an election and of
course it had to be Putin well they've
been laying down the groundwork for this
for many years now I mean the Cold War
essentially never ended it's only
escalating from here there were many
proxy wars even recently Syria was a
major proxy war between the East and the
West now that theater moved the the the
conflict still continues in Syria but
that theater moved to Ukraine it's
expanding it's growing and for the last
few years the corporate media with the
intelligence agencies have been laying
down the groundwork Russia Russia Russia
Russia Russia non-stop even when there
was is reasons not to criticize them
there's a lot of things you can
criticize about Russia there's a lot of
things that they did in Georgia and
Crimea that you could of course heavily
criticize with the you know destruction
of civil liberties and human rights in
their country sure there's a lot of
things you could do that but the
Intelligentsia here in the United States
made stuff up just to point the finger
and blame on Russia I think I know what
really happened
before all of this back in December
Putin had a secret meeting with Joe
Biden right and they were like hey
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
fake this war right you know why because
then Putin's like I'm gonna use nukes
and then you respond aliens reveal
themselves and shut down the nukes and
that's how I get them to come out of
hiding that proves it I'm kidding by the
way let's jump to this next story from
the television
if what they're doing is a Psy up and
they're trying to get me to beg for a
new world order it's starting to work
because any kind of order Global Order
would be well maybe not any but would be
better than a nuclear war I mean this is
the best way to do it you get Biden and
Putin you know firing nukes at each
other and then whoever you want to
actually run your new government comes
out and says people the war is bad it's
not working join me and we'll come up
we'll bring about a cryptocurrency yes
you know single currency for the planet
will end all of this ship in your in
your wrist and you will be immune to
nuclear fallout Central Bank digital
currency which the US Federal Reserve
and many other countries are putting
into practice that alien stuff there are
some uh very notable people that do
believe aliens have prevented nuclear
war on this planet there are some right
that's what defense Ministers of Canada
yeah yeah no no I'm expanding on it
Jason's shaking his head here uh whether
you agree with them or disagree with
them this is the the bigger context to
what Tim is saying here thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there